on the 26th of September 2022 a 570
kilogram spacecraft the size of a
refrigerator rammed into an asteroid at
six kilometers per second launched
aboard the fossil fueled powered Falcon
9 the dinosaurs finally clapped back
66 million years after the asteroid that
ended the dinosaurs an unsuspecting
asteroid was struck with an impact
equivalent of three tons of TNT and we
caught it all on film this mission is
perhaps the most important experiment
NASA has ever performed data and
information that could one day save us
from the same fate as the dinosaurs
the asteroid we struck dimorphos is 160
meters in diameter much smaller than the
10 kilometer wide asteroids that
exterminated the dinosaurs all those
years ago but large enough to unleash
over 300 megatons of energy if it
collided with Earth six times more
powerful than the most powerful nuclear
weapon ever used
in the week since scientists have been
studying the results calculating how
effective our first asteroid redirection
test was however the work that went into
this mission Far extends the last month
of scientific study for years scientists
and Engineers carefully planned which
asteroid to hit how to hit it and how to
confidently and quickly measure the
effect of the Collision
to understand the achievement of the
dart Mission let's dive into the
engineering and physics of its Planet
defense mission
the dart spacecraft itself hosted no
scientific instruments designed to be a
low-cost spacecraft with just the tools
it needed to complete its Mission
cameras to spot its Target star trackers
to navigate through space a propulsion
system to direct it toward its Target
antenna systems to speak with Earth and
an onboard computer whose software has
its roots in military missile
Technologies
however darsh did release a small
italian-made spacecraft designed to
record the Collision giving us this
footage showing a massive plume of
debris being ejected from the asteroid
on impact
the Falcon 9 rocket did the majority of
the work in directing dirt toward its
Target dimorphos this was a unique
Target chosen for a very important
reason
it's a moonless a tiny Moon orbiting the
larger asteroid didimos
dart's camera gave us a glimpse of
didimos as it sailed by at a Breakneck
speed closing down the remaining 920
kilometers in just two and a half
minutes it computed and adjusted its
trajectory using hydrazine thrusters
guiding the spacecraft to a head-on
impact with the moonlit in these final
moments dirt shut down its thrusters
allowing the camera to take clear images
of its impending doom and giving us a
clear picture of the rock we just
obliterated 11 million kilometers away
so why this rock in particular
there are countless asteroids orbiting
the Sun however in order to study the
results of impact we need a specific
kind of asteroid
first dimorphos was passing close to
Earth passing by at 11 million
kilometers at the time of impact
we have tracked dimorphos and have
confident predictions of where the
asteroid is going to be at any given
point in time this allowed us to choose
an optimal window for Collision our
model showed that on October 4th 2022
the asteroid would be at its closest
approach for the next 40 years the next
time it would be this close to Earth be
2062 this was the perfect opportunity
however we struck it a week early
because the asteroid would be at its
brightest to us at its closest approach
allowing us to better observe the
results of the Collision
this is the next reason this asteroid
was chosen the goal of the double
asteroid redirection test was to
redirect an asteroid with just enough
Force to change its trajectory by a
marginal amount enough to avoid a
collision with Earth a change of just
one percent could be enough to avoid a
catastrophe But Here Lies The Dilemma
for scientists how do we measure such a
small change in trajectory of an object
11 million kilometers away even the
footage from a spacecraft near the
Collision is not much to go off
confidently measuring an impact with an
asteroid orbiting the Sun would take
years as we'd need to measure multiple
orbits to assess the differences before
and after the impact instead scientists
turned to Binary systems for answers
there are systems of asteroids where one
smaller moonless orbits a larger
asteroid all we need to know is that we
changed the velocity of a moving rock in
space it doesn't matter if it's orbiting
the Sun or orbiting another rock however
not any binary system would make this
experiment feasible it is essential that
we can measure the effectiveness of the
crash from Earth for this the orbiting
moonlit should have an eclipsing path
meaning that viewed from Earth it would
pass in front of and behind the asteroid
during its orbit the light reflecting
from these two asteroids that we see
here on Earth appears as a single point
of light and each time dimorphos passes
in front of didimos that light dims
using sensitive earth-based telescopes
we have timed these patterns to measure
the orbit of dimorphos at 11 hours 55
minutes using these same techniques we
can measure the change in orbit
dimorphos is only visible from the
southern hemisphere so NASA reserved
time on telescopes located in Chile
South Africa Australia and New Zealand
joining the earth-based telescopes Webb
and Hubble were also used to image the
asteroids at the time of impact of
course to achieve all this we first
needed to hit the asteroid that was no
easy feat the asteroid was too far away
to manually direct the spacecraft there
would be a lag of 1.5 minutes
six kilometers per second a lag this
large would help the spacecraft travel
over 540 kilometers before receiving
instructions when trying to hit a Target
only 160 meters in diameter lags like
this required an autonomous navigation
system
the spacecraft was loaded with the
camera attached to a small 20 centimeter
wide telescope and circuitry no more
powerful than that of a PlayStation 1.
every second it would take a picture and
calculate the thrust needed to stay on
chorus working very similarly to visual
Guidance Software used in military
applications like the javelin missile
Dart used 12 directional thrusters to
hit the small dim moonless
dirt was also equipped with the next
generation of ion thrusters next C which
is three times more powerful than NASA's
previous generation ion Thruster inster
ion thrusters are highly efficient
accelerating heavy ions of xenon to
extreme speeds of 40 kilometers per
second using an electromagnetic field 10
times faster than a traditional rocket
engine
these ion thrusters were powered by new
specially developed lightweight solar
cells that deploy from a roll called a
roll out solar array or Rosa this solar
array was successfully tested on the ISS
in 2017 although in a strangely
hilarious video the arrays were gently
ejected from the ISS because there was a
fault in retracting them at the end of
the test part of the solar array was
also used to demonstrate a new solar
collector technology that would
concentrate sunlight on high efficiency
panels increasing their power deep in
our solar system where solar radiation
rapidly drops off thanks to the inverse
Square law
a technology that would be extremely
useful for powering an ion Thruster
allowing us to reach asteroids further
from Earth and giving us a better chance
of changing their trajectory early these
systems were successfully tested on dirt
however Ed Reynolds the DART program
manager at APL revealed in a post-impact
briefing that the next SEA Thruster was
actually only tested for a short
two-hour period during flight an
unexpected issue arose that could have
cost 100 amps of current to run through
the Thruster which it had not been
tested to withstand forcing the team to
make a decision to not continue testing
the Thruster instead relying completely
on the hydrazine thrusters to focus on
the primary asteroid redirect Mission
and while this is disappointing finding
a new issue is an important part of the
testing process and it didn't impact the
mission at all
the mission itself was a massive success
after just two weeks of gathering data
NASA announced on October 10th the
effects of the Collision
striking only 17 meters from the
asteroid Center there's practically
struck the bullseye not just changing
its orbit by one percent but by a
relatively massive 4.5 percent reducing
its orbit around didimos by 32 whole
minutes down from 11 hours 55 minutes to
11 hours 23 minutes
this is a mission worth celebrating we
are now confident we can deflect an
asteroid like dimorphos if the need
arises Beyond Moon missions Beyond Mars
missions beyond all the understanding
NASA and other space agencies provide us
this Mission has clear understandable
importance we now have data and tools in
our Arsenal to protect our planets we
are now a little safer on this little
rock floating through the vast
mysterious expanses of space
this mission was primarily designed to
gather data on how a collision like this
would affect the orbit of an asteroid
there were many questions to be answered
about the geological composition of the
asteroid and how that would affect the
transfer of momentum from dirt to
dimorphos especially as most asteroids
of this size are simply piles of rubble
that have coalesced due to gravity over
time and aren't a single solid Mass
making exact predictions on the
Collision physics and how the orbit
would be affected very difficult
basic calculations of gravitational
physics are pretty easy to learn however
and understanding them gives you all
sorts of fun Powers unlocking the
knowledge of space travel and planetary
motion you can learn more about that by
taking this course on brilliant and when
you are done you can move over to our
very own real engineering course all
this is available to you by signing up
to Brilliance free trial with the link
in the description and if you found
value in the math and science courses
you took for free and I'm sure you will
you can continue with 20 off the annual
premium subscription this offer is only
available to the first 500 people to
sign up our in-depth interactive course
teaches you about the physics of orbit
and traditional rocket launches before
teaching you about the fundamentals of
kinetic launch systems a course designed
to help you understand spin launch the
subject of a recent documentary you can
get access to that course right now and
all of brilliant's other curated
interactive courses by clicking the link
in the description a fantastic course to
start is computer science fundamentals
the perfect course for high school or
college students starting their Journey
on computer science this course will
teach you core computer science Concepts
and when you are done you can move on to
more advanced courses like programming
with python brilliant teachers with
interesting and fun interactive courses
that challenge you along the way making
the learning process much easier and
more rewarding and they're adding
content monthly so there's always
something new to learn you can get
started for free by clicking the link on
screen right now the first 500 people to
do so will get 20 off Brilliance annual
premium subscription